en arrivant sur le spot j'ai repéré
quelque chose dans le bas côté donc
venez voir une petite télé cathodique
donc la sas a rien à faire ici on va
remonter pour l'amener à la déchetterie
un stage à bord
salut à tous ces pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui partie de pêche à leyment
sur un nouveau spot
ouais voilà donc c'est un petit peu
marécageux c'est un petit peu un petit
peu sale mais ils doivent en plein de
choses a déjà on a trouvé ça dans le
ruisseau à côté donc c'est à prouver
ouais ça promet mais bon ça a déjà été
fait on nous l'a dit donc on a parlé
avec le monsieur qui habite juste à côté
et nous a dit qu'on avait déjà sorti un
scooter il ya trois semaines environ
mais on est certain de trouver autre
chose on attaque tout de suite
voilà le seul truc qui est dommage sur
cet endroit c'est qu'il ya plein de bois
1 c'est pas des moucherons un coup dur
moi aussi tu as plein de merdes a ici
ailleurs moi c'est un morceau de cadres
cadres de vélo ou de mob faudra essayer
de sortir la bâche après l' habitat
quelque chose c'est un morceau de chair
une chaise
non ouais moi aussi j'ai quelque chose
pareil pour cette chaise un stylet et
j'ai parlé protoxyde d azote donc ici il
y avait des drogués un char besoin de
toi là c'est un gros tube
je vais rattraper l'autre côté sacrément
lourd ça fait bouger même le tronc des
rires là bas on va venir invasive vient
m'aider on monte on monte petit à petit
problème c'est les arbres pas si l'ours
n'est pas un arbre deux arbres nous
accrocher non mais déjà si on prend
comme ça sur chaque côté après voilà
c'est parti ça va pas jusqu'au les maïs
bloc de tous d'accord sac est lourd qui
ont la même dans le coin non en galère
faut le tenir droit encore tu attends
lemay droit d'abord voilà lé droit
bon je pense qu'il est bien là au moins
il ne viendra plus c'est ça que tension
on peut pas partir avec
donc on le laisse sur le côté on
continue ce jour là les disques durs
audience a alors fait un truc regarde on
dirait une sorte de tour de toyota au
nom ou alors c'est une route carrosse
c'est énorme c'est trop dur et ben oui
mais c'est sur 100 % ces normes
l'ancêtre des voitures l énorme ouai
c'est trop bien c'est entendu voir
regarder c'est une roue il y avait les
les anneaux en bois incroyable trottier
il ya des vieilles choses comme quoi
même si c'est fait ouais en plus ça
c'est bon ça y est le bio bobo c'est
pour super oui c'est du fer et du bois
de d'arrivée regardez magnifique c'est
magnifique ça or la taille par rapport à
toi entière c'est très rare je pense
ouais je dirais sourya pas le bois au
milieu mais il a peut-être été coupée
mais peut-être superbe un truc assez
inventive à la loi les costauds du vol
de scooter quand même assez way
voilà peut-être le scooter avec way
allez un antivol auquel s'est remplie si
typiquement je pense que ça s'est jamais
nettoyé contrairement au canal du midi
oui oui tu le vois au mur grâce est trop
bien ce genre de spot c'est régale pas
neiges c'est ta première neige rasta je
sais pas moi aussi j'ai plein de trucs
c'est un cadre allez je les ai pas
jeunes celui là
regarde d'ailleurs comme n'est pas jeune
bah non c'est juste qu'il est tout
autant rendu est bien apte à une peau
moustiques thème on attrape moustiques
casas et oya téléphone non c'est pas un
téléphone ça aux deux sacs à dos et un
téléphone je crois mais les vieux c'est
un téléphone fixe
ouais non c'est quoi cette bulle
non c'est un feu c'est un feu de scooter
à un harry peut-être il ya sachets à
saché avec une énorme chaîne s'est
accroché avec la chaîne de l'accrocher
dedans c'est bizarre c'est étonnant oula
oula oula
bon là bachelet perdu mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça un frein ou de motos ou de
mob pas un frein ouais si si c'est ça
que le frein sympa allégé revenir la
bâche lara non encore raté une poivrière
ouais elle a un peu cassé j'ai quelque
chose d'assez conséquent oula oula
qu'est ce que c'est encore
quinton donc à bastien oui oui c'est un
réservoir de mobylette
ouais toujours les 104 je crois mais
sauf que celle-ci est vraiment dans
l'eau depuis longtemps à a gelé je vais
je crois le truc et au plein d'essence
ou la voile à mon avis c'était juste
dessous faut qu un filtre à essence no
way
ces morceaux du scout c'est ça qui est
ce qui perdra s'était embrasée du coup
ça paraissait lourd double protoxyde bon
voilà une demi heure qui galère sur
quelque chose tout les sens qu'à la
barre il avait un truc
ok on coupe une lame d'un couteau
récents en squeeze récent bond étonnante
c'est quand même étonnant sympa tu as
fini par la vente on truque mais c'est
pas lui ouais tombe pas sur tout prend
pas tu accordes si tu tombes away moteur
deux cartes 1,14 ou scouts ouais c'est
vrai que ça accroche pas très bien ça
j'ai essayé d'aider damas
non pas encore ouais il ya des vieux
trucs des vieilles choses là merci bonne
journée aller maintenant on va essayer
ce côté du pont probablement jamais été
fait lorsque je suis lancé que ça a été
fait avait enlevé le tout ce qui était
au dessus nous on a gratté dans la vase
maintenant avant celui là de côté c'est
parti pour la pêche
à quand les mangues touche falot c'est
pas bon signe
mon élément et touchent pas l'eau allait
toucher l'eau pour repêcher de
l'alligator cent des trucs non sans un
truc là mais bon je l' ai assez un cadre
morceaux de cadres il n'est pas très
vieux sympa à bono ferraille comme on
aime
oh c'est quoi ça non trop gras non c'est
pas une pompe à 2/4 scherwey tamadon
cité recherche pistolet ça coûte
d'ailleurs quand à appuyer énorme
barry lane un truc là les gars c'est un
générateur au moteur des morts mais je
peux pas c'est quoi ça les trains devant
chez moi
ok c'est un quator de scouts entier ah
non il est pas entier c'est l'autre
morceau entier
en fait ils ont jeté un côté wayne avait
plusieurs mois c'est une polaire là il
s'en vend ce cas dans les poches 30
billets 30 billets dédicace à saugues
man en prison et anelka s'est passé
comme à lens
la très bien mes mains dans mes poches
mais j'peux pas parce qu'il ya trop de
pêcheurs du dimanche il a la chance
nickel tu sais pourquoi parce que moi je
touche pas à mon pote aux as et vraiment
pas
j'ai quelque chose aux attendes il ya
sachet avec il y va doucement tu
attrapes le sachet donc nous là où
l'islande la hongrie
il avait du sable dedans je crois tu
auras star et j'ai vu ce qu'on a pêché
ont tapé sheedy bon kaka bon on fout sa
cellule fois depuis tout à l'heure je
sors des morceaux de vélo là donc je
l'aï donc il doit être là bas j'ai un
truc assez dégueulasse grosses barres de
fer bon ne pas reproduire debout sur le
pont mais on est des professionnels
justement il n'y a pas de profondeur
dans un cadre il est bien vieux suis là
et les normes et sur 5 4
ouais on dirait camer be et moto alors
qu'il faut d'échappement ouais je sais
pas c'est bizarre encore wade et ses
morceaux de mombasa oui c'est un morceau
de mobylette
ouais t'es tu crois les sens c'est
vraiment pourri ça des proto petite aya
un truc de fou j'ai eu alors c'est quoi
c'est quoi ça non c'est un filtre
essence ou quad un cocker a mais ça
c'est parce qu'il avait eue crise
justement c'est un accumulateur de
suspension de voiture ces morceaux de
bagnole ça je crois quand même le mettre
sur coup sur le côté au cas où mais
normalement il n'ya pas de soucy
on ira l'authentifier et vérifier ça
avant de faire des bêtises avec ben
voilà ça aura fait un heureux pays doit
être plein d'eau
ouais je suis assez lourd c'est super
lot
a montreuil dessous façon pas abîmer le
chiot ouais enfin basculer après attend
il est plein d'eau encore temps doit il
va être dessous quand tu vires tavannes
dessous ouais ocha
vas-y vas-y pour glisser allez c'est bon
ça ouais
et oui merci
on a par contre coupé en 2 sympa semaine
aleasoft inc fermeture pêche au bar ben
tu fais tout et oui mon pote tu es
vraiment qu'aucun c'est encore bout de
cadre ou un bout de voitures tout
voiture que si c'était d'un boulodrome
salon sympa ici je pense qu'il y aurait
de quoi nous occuper pendant des jours
après on va rendre ce coin paradisiaque
on pourra s'y baigner
tu feras pas des mots quand on aura fini
de nettoyer ce n'est pas une piscine non
plus
o 1 étoile une étoile est née gens
savent pas à quoi elle est pleine voir
la vidéo va aller at il perdu la battre
sur le fil au mans à morceaux de voiture
et ça je sais pas ce que c'est si vous
avez une idée en commentaire mécanisme
bizarre j'ai une branche et install son
ânon oui moi aussi tout aussi en même
temps du coup non mais un chacun et on
va se baigner dans le canal le mieux est
plus beau que le tien ouais vraiment il
a pris cher regarde où il doit y avoir
des trucs cochons dans ce cas qu on va y
aller
jani avec cela ouais je sais pas ce
qu'on peut faire avec pas mal mais du
coup il ya des bonnes choses je suis
finalement rien parce que de la merde du
soutien-gorge aussi fin qu'un projet pas
les gants allez tous renoncé à prendre à
mon art est derrière trop de la journée
allait il est motivé
et tel mobile est trop lâche 1 509 ira
dans le tas de ferraille
[Musique]
allez maintenant tu la moto tout tête
ouais cool c'est bon on arrête aller à
la prochaine dépôts d'encombrants et de
déchets verts interdits
regardez tout ce qu'on a sorti belle
dépollution encore une fois on va partir
avec le tout bien sûr